hey guys welcome to the mkbhd video of
the twelve giveaways of Christmas 2010
and even if you don't celebrate
Christmas happy holidays
if you like this video and leave a
comment any comment you'll be entered to
win a pair of the beats by dre studio
headphones of course you should be
subscribed to this channel to see the
uploaded winners video on December 20th
I've already showed the studios on video
before on this channel but this is not
the pair you'll be winning actually the
winner will receive its ships straight
to their address from monster cable as
I'll provide that address and buy it for
them with the adjust they provide so now
that you've liked this video and loved
to comment we can throw in a bit more if
this channel reaches 15,000 subscribers
by December 20th the end date of the
giveaway I will be giving away two pairs
of beats by dre headphones to two
different individual winners so like I
said there's a ton of incentive to
possibly tell your friends about the
speeds giveaway either way good luck and
happy Holidays to you all that's it for
this giveaway video as part of the
Macintosh tips 12 giveaways of Christmas
marathon that's going out right now more
infos in the description of course so
long story short there are a few more
giveaways going on right at this moment
that you should know again know about so
anyway click below if you want to see
more information at Macintosh tips calm
all right guys happy commenting and
Happy Holidays and I'll see you on the
20th peace